according to the LA times the number up
californians
aged 5264 who live in their parents
homes
has surged in recent years people 50
264 moving back in every other is just
the Millennials moving back in with mom
and dad know
its people in middle to upper middle-age
we've got more info for you
for seven years through 2012 the number
of Californians age 50 to 64 who live in
their parents homes what
sixty 7 percent to about a hundred
ninety-four
thousand seems insane among 18- to
24-year-olds 1.6 million californians
have moved in with their parents though
that a 33 percent jump in 2006 the pace
is still have that
a B-fifty 264 age group
I am there there's so much here
again about her in that age group yet I
am as well correct
you looking great lottery loiter Isaiah
but mister
a is this really an economic thing do
you think that that really is what's
going on here that these people just are
fallen on hard economic times it seems
weird for that age group is in it
yeah it does but I feel like um the
first I hope this means that we can't
stop reading money I'll try n pieces
item is not as the Millennials like
let's return from pieces about 50 to
64-year-olds that was one of the first
things railroading of their parents Yap
wet days a jerk with a nice when you saw
this because it was like oh they're not
just
da and how you know millennial yes
euro-area
so isn't it refreshing yes indeed some
other age group B besmirch
I'm easy with a boomers yeah it's sad
it's sad because like you know of their
economic issues a play and I'm it's more
stigmatized back home when you're fifty
then when you are
20 but um yeah I'll say it is it is kind
of like when the things we look for her
trends like
these lazy Millennials I feel like these
issues kinda far
the economy at large not just like a
Gerber ager a people being
you know lazy not working right so we
the bad economy altogether people just
attacked the Millennials because they're
the ones getting in the workforce in a
bad economy not the way they were so
obnoxious and it's like they were easy
targets
things we don't feel well you know my
goodness arm
should we should be judging these you
know look in your other
you know been your look at Italy almost
everyone lived with their mother in here
8 should we be more like Italy I think
that I think we should be more like
Italy
mcallister yeah I leave know it's
I think it's at more than anything and I
think it's a statement on the economy in
a huge way but i think is also seen on
the table jobs that are available and
a lot of people in this age group are
trained for jobs that no longer exist
and aren't properly train for the jobs
that are starting to exist
I'm I and the stupid 50 is
not you know that middle-aged and
there's not a a great way to train
pub time dove middle-aged people to
learn
the you know you want to you I do job
training you want to
give people a chance to get educated
enough to get back into the workforce
but
move so quickly that by the time you
know somebody is trying to computers
in the nineties is already if they have
been staying up with that is already
totally behind I route now yeah so it's
not just a bad economy with an they're
not
train properly for the for the jobs that
exist right that we put too much a
premium
I'm getting at the house like even this
reminds me like every episode of The
Cosby Show
right clip was always trying to get
those Leo now
up debt al well we do know culturally
you know you're right though in Europe
it's all the same in many other
countries is not the same in the US
has a weird thing about kids going to
college and never coming back
which is not realistic in this economy
so I think that um
yet the weird cultural thing I don't
know with other cultures
are so into people who have been out of
the house for thirty years
then coming back right but our some yeah
I'm you to see Michael
a weird thing we've had been conditioned
to believe that you have to kind of get
out immediately and never look back
yeah well it also makes sense though
that what started this terrible
economy a was honored surgery done but
with started
the economy was the housing crisis and
so
a lot of the people in the 50 to 64
Adrian probably
owned houses that were foreclosed upon
and so they were probably former
homeowners who are now renters who can
afford the rent any word like
if the natural conclusion I love people
who were foreclosed on
eight years ago yeah there's definitely
let me a reason they're gone is there
something nice actually about people
this age moving back in you know your
elderly parents at a rally in the 80's
or 90's at this point
and you know people do it's usually
thought of the other way that the
elderly parent moved in with the
a child or they kick them off to Shady
Pines I so does get one dollar goes
right they appreciate it I am
so but is there something nice about
this that we should actually respect
more you know like in Japan where they
really have a respect for the elderly
that we sorted don't have here he's a
bum me out about the LA Times piece
um the woman in the P says that it was
because we're twins that you have back
and if they had not been around to it
was in a car
so I was like a small reading this
because my mom read that I'd rather live
in my car that with my mom
think should be a little upset yeah I
will we link to the article in The
description by the way he can find out
about a bit more about her yeah it's
just depressing it's so sad and it is
nice
to be with family and to be but nobody
wants to come back at hand
the will also nobody wants to be written
up in LA Times about how they came back
at it
well here already embarrassing enough
but to go to
be like yeah so than my live really fell
apart and I have to live with my parents
%uh my kids like that sucks think a
really read about
up